quickly before we get started on this
let's just review a little bit
okay so we looked at ordering integers
do you remember that
so we said integers they have order
okay now that might seem a bit obvious
to you you're like of course numbers
have order
uh well if you hang around for a little
walking maths you will learn about
different kinds of numbers
that you can't just put in a row and say
well this one's smaller and this one's
in the middle
and this one's bigger it's a little more
complicated than that
okay so integers have order and you did
a bit of practice doing that
okay i also looked at the number line
we looked at that very briefly which is
a great way to represent
numbers and also to have their
comparison with each other yes
if i put something on the board in
general it's a good idea to write it
i'll probably tell you if i don't want
you to write it
um but that's why i think it's helpful
and correctly if i'm wrong but i think
the most recent thing you looked at was
adding integers is that right yeah
i realized it was a little while ago
and um you know drum beats and swimming
carnivals notwithstanding
um you'd have plenty of other things to
keep you busy but that's sort of where
we went so i want to go after this one
again
adding integers right what is that sound
i do believe it's
about
so let's do some examples okay we'll
start with simple ones
ones that you already know from counting
numbers two plus three that's a nice
easy one it's all together
all right let's let's do another one
example how about let's throw a negative
in there shall we
now by the way before we progress
past this don't forget that we
distinguished a little bit between
a minus sign that's here and a minus
sign that's
here okay do you remember this let's do
this so
just quickly what is the answer to both
of them
it's three i did it he's a genius
okay the answers are both the same but
we say them in quiet different ways
do you remember how we say them okay you
may actually like to write this down
on the side the way i write this or
rather the way i would say it
is or put some quote marks in
four and the operation between them is a
plus
four plus right but then
what you're adding the thing you're
adding to it
is a negative number right it's four
plus negative
one so what we're trying to discourage
is saying it as four plus minus one
what's the difference it seems very very
little but the idea is that
negative one right that's the number
that negative sign
stays with the one okay they kind of
like bunnies and then they go with each
other
so that's four plus negative one this on
the other hand right
it's not a negative number it's a an
operation and the operation is minus
so we would read that as 4 minus
1. okay now in practice
what does this actually mean well
because we get the same answer it's not
that big a deal
negatives and minus are both kind of
like
having a direction we call this um
integers directed number right
how many direction and the negative or
the minus means turn around
that's all it means okay so for instance
this four
okay we went for so we're going to do it
like this
so here's my number line okay now you
always start off
at zero i don't know if you remember
when we had a discussion about
what integers were and what they weren't
we were tossing up about zero i said
it's really important
one of the reasons why is because it's
always where you start is it over my
head close enough
is that all right okay so like a halo
that
that's that's really unsettling the
first thing we're going to do is let's
do four minus one that's nice and easy
okay so four minus one start from zero
you go
one two three
four wow revolutionary i know right okay
now we're doing four minus one so i'm
turning around there you go no big deal
right
okay so what's going in here you're
still going
that way there's a plus right
but how far do you go that way
well after you've gone four i still end
up over here right
what about the negative one what does
that mean it means turn around
so in essence that's why you get the
same number okay no problem
all right one last example sorry that's
example three
example oh we already skipped let's get
something back
let's do minus five minus
seven okay minus five minus seven
what's it mean what's it mean yeah minus
twelve
minus twelve that's right now where did
my soul come from
right you start from zero the first
minus sign tells you
turn around so off you go and i don't
have space here but i'd go
five units right then the minus seven
means
keep going that way right so that's why
i'm going to get so far
i'd go out of the room i suppose and
that's why you've got such a big
negative number
all right now skipped a little bit ahead
of myself when i gave you this one
because we're looking at subtracting
integers now right
so where it gets really interesting this
is no longer a revision
but let's do subtraction
okay when we're combining these things
together
so let's do it again
so it's just like actually those are
really bad stuff
i can do better i'll save it until the
next poll
two minus eight means i'm going this way
those two units one
two and then i'm turning around and off
i go so how far will i end up once i've
gotten
all the way over the side excellent
now hold on a second yes but not quite
this answer on the end should be an
integer shouldn't it okay
no operations that's kind of what the
point was to get rid of operations
so it's not really minus six it's
negative six not that much of a
difference but
it's subtle um if you how many of you
bought a calculator already and
have you got it with you great get it
out i'll do that
you did too get it out
and
i'll point actually it's the same as
this right same one yeah good okay
i'll point out to you it's a really
really uh
small thing there which some of you
might not really notice unless i pointed
out
which is that where's the minus sign
where is the minus sign
it's down near the bottom right hand
corner just above equals isn't it bottom
right
good i always get that right make
something on facebook okay so there's
minus and you can see it's all locked
together with the other
operations but there is actually
not just minus but there's a negative
button on the calculator can anyone see
it
who can find it do you know where it is
yeah where is it can you describe where
to stay um it's
yeah good okay so it looks like this in
case you haven't done it yet
okay now you can actually use that
button and you can see
it's not quite like the minus it's a bit
smaller so you can actually tell the
difference when you type it up
okay so that's the negative button
all right so that's kind of handy it's
there for a reason
because these two things are different
ideas okay
negative
is the direction of the integer but
minus is an operation
i suppose the difference is kind of like
what kind of a word is negative you know
you guys know he says
wordy words like nouns
verbs adjectives what other kinds of
words do you know any other words yep
adverbs are there any other yep
pronouns excellent any others
yeah wow that's a big one
is it prayer positions
um there's others there's conjunctions
that's a big one
one more yeah proverbs oh
that's that's interesting because um
that is a word
and it certainly does seem like it
should be in the list but it kind of
means something different we do tend to
uh pronounce it proverb um but it's
a little different i'm gonna leave that
one off on the side for a little while
if we're good by the end of the lesson
i'll tell you what it means
now have a look i reckon this is a good
enough list
minus where does minus fit
in our list think about it for a second
think about it for a second
hmm okay pounds up who thinks it's a
noun
anyone take it okay that's all right
who reckons it's a verb okay one two
oh yeah three four
three and a half four it's a four okay
all right
four okay who thinks it's an adjective
one two three four five
who wants who wants a label option one
of the later options
you mean up here okay all right i'll
save you some time
and i will tell you that it's not any of
these
watching that one okay now that's uh
that's ten of you have put your hand up
so far
and there are two four six eight ten
twelve
uh 17 22 in the room which means
that 12 of you are confused and that's
totally okay
it's totally okay which one is it it's
can we work it out we're talking about
minus aren't we okay
four minus one four minus one
something is happening isn't it there's
an action that's taking place
an action is taking place which kind of
word
gives you an action can we get some
examples yeah
it's actually a verb right so like jump
or or fly or eat
these are all things that are they're
not that kind of
fine too many videos
um especially like in skateboarding
so something is happening when you minus
something
you subtract something there's an action
that takes place
it's actually a verb what about
negatives
what about negative which one's that can
we make this one out that's it
now it's a bit tricky because um here's
there for a second against that
english is a bit of a pain sometimes
because sometimes one word could be into
different things
like i said fly or fly can be a verb but
it can be a noun as well
right well we talk about negative we
don't mean like film negatives you know
when things are
backwards and columns we mean negative
numbers
negative one right
so the one is the thing it's the object
the negative
tells you something about the number
which means it's an adjective
right so you've got minus being a verb
and negative being
it's a descriptive word okay so that's
why we have different buttons